[Music]
we've created the prototype flip cover
or a smartphone incorporating an
additional eating display this way
content can be shared between the
regular smartphone and the additional
e'en cover a capacitive touch area
integrated within the fabric allows the
user to easily select different types of
content such as calendar items travel
documents notes pictures to-do lists etc
our implementation has five mace holders
to store content each place over can
store multiple pages of content items an
app allows the user to manage the five
place and works by replacing content or
adding multiple content items to a
single place holder the number in the
top left corner indicates the amount of
items in the place owner and the user
can toggle between images screenshots
and other phone content can easily be
added using the same app our flipped
over design makes it easy to pair
content side by side it also ensures you
always carry around an item exposing
quality even when your phone battery and
slap
you
[Music]